hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
bild live breaking news denn in nizza
kam es jetzt zu einem messer
terroranschlag muss man fast sagen so
beschreiben dass die lokalen politiker
insgesamt sollen drei menschen dabei
gestorben seien bei mir im studio jetzt
mein kollege simon schütz sieht man was
wissen wir bereits über die situation in
frankreich in nutzer also treffen
ständig neue informationen ein was wir
bis jetzt wissen sind es sind drei
menschen getötet worden und der täter
ist festgenommen worden
der bürgermeister war direkt vor ort und
sprach von terror
wir wissen dass eine frau in der nähe
eine kirche geköpft worden ist ein
weiterer mann ist durch messerstiche in
den hals getötet worden
außerdem ist bekannt dass der täter
alabbar geschrieben hat das erinnert
natürlich auch wieder an die enthauptung
des lehrers samuel partie das war auch
erst diesen monat das heißt zum zweiten
mal jetzt innerhalb weniger tage ist
frankreich jetzt erschüttert von diesem
messer terror gibt es aber wir haben
bewusst gesagt war medienberichten
zufolge sieht man also schon parallelen
zwischen diesen beiden fällen ja es
deutet alles darauf hin also der
bürgermeister wie gesagt hat indirekt
davon gesprochen dass alles auf einen
terroristischen anschlag hindeutet und
natürlich vor dem hintergrund von dieser
tat vor kurzem wieder das aloha bar und
wieder eine enthauptung dass jemand
geköpft worden ist deutet wirklich alles
auf eine parallele hin und der konflikt
hatte sich ja auch zugespitzt in den
letzten wochen nach dem jahr bei dem
lehrer bei seiner partie da ging es ja
um die karikaturen mit diesem mohammed
karikaturen die im unterricht gezeigt
wurden und da hat ja auch der präsident
makro in einer sehr bewegenden ansprache
das ganze verteidigung gesagt man wird
das auch weiterhin machen
es gab ja dann gewisse konflikte gerade
mit islamisten die natürlich gerade bei
diesen mohammed-karikaturen sich
angegriffen fühlen und jetzt sieht man
scheinbar die zweite tat muss natürlich
noch nicht genau sie über die
hintergründe man weiß auch dass schüsse
gefallen sind die polizei sagt jetzt
diese schüsse sind von den polizisten
ausgegangen
derzeit scheint dass man von einem täter
aus zu gehen aber es treffend ständig
nur informationen kann auch sein dass
dann noch mehr dahinter steckt ja jetzt
gerade erfahren will dass die pariser
antiterror staatsanwaltschaft jetzt also
die ermittlungen übernimmt das wurde
gerade bekannt gegeben es geht also um
den vorwurf des mordes in
verbindung mit einem terroristischen
vorhaben und noch einmal
zusammenzufassen es gab diesen
messerangriff heute ja vor wenigen
momenten eigentlich erst drei menschen
sind dabei ums leben gekommen
medienberichten zufolge soll eine frau
gekauft worden seien das alles in der
nähe einer kirche der kirche notre dame
in nizza in der küstenstadt in
frankreich und simon das gerade gesagt
man hat auch von sieben bis acht
schüssen gehört da sagt die polizei
jetzt selber aber schon die kommen von
ihnen das war also nicht auch noch der
mutmassliche täter der bereits
festgenommene genau also scheint so als
seien diese schüsse von der polizei
selbst gewesen und der täter muss er
mindestens mit einem messer bewaffnet
gewesen sein und die frau eben zu köpfen
und den anderen mann den er am hals
getötet
dabei soll sich um 70 jährigen mann
gehandelt haben das weiß man bis jetzt
alles weitere ist noch nicht bekannt ja
und das alles also jetzt nur wenige tage
nachdem der laden lehrer samuel partie
auch in frankreich geköpft worden ist
von einem 18-jährigen das alles simon
hat es gerade schon gesagt wegen
karikaturen die ja in seinem unterricht
gezeigt hatte er wollte damit auf die
meinungsfreiheit hinweisen und wurde
dann am 18
diesen monats geköpft wir haben bis
jetzt nur die medienberichte zu dem was
da passiert ist aber wie gerade schon
gesagt die staatsanwaltschaft die
antiterror staatsanwaltschaft in paris
übernimmt jetzt die ermittlungen zu all
dem das ganze auch noch in der nähe
einer kirche das hat natürlich noch
einmal einen besonderen besonders
bitteren beigeschmack muss man dann dazu
sagen es soll auch mehrere verletzte
gegeben haben das heißt die situation
ist noch immer nicht ganz klar
genau die situation ist eines klar ist
ein groß angelegter polizeieinsatz
natürlich weiß man noch nicht ob bei den
drei verletzten bis jetzt noch nicht
genau was bekannt streben mehrere von
denen vielleicht auch in lebensgefahr
oder nicht und natürlich diese dieser
wahl geschmack das sind ja mehr einer
kirche war bedeutete natürlich umso mehr
auf diesem islamistischen hintergrund
dann verbund mit dem rabatt gibt es an
der einen terroristischen oder
islamistischen hintergrund dieser tat
eigentlich zu diesem zeitpunkt schon gar
kein zweifel mehr
also das alles jetzt zu der situation
momentan in nizza die polizei ist mit
einem großaufgebot dort in der nähe eine
kirche denn es kam dort zu einem messer
terrorangriff drei menschen sind dabei
verstorben
eine frau soll enthauptet worden sein
das berichten jetzt französische medien
wir halten sie natürlich weiterhin auf
dem laufenden bei bild.de alles zu
diesem messer terror von frankreich bis
dahin auf wiedersehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren